the iron dome you've heard about it in
the news but what is it
despite its Truman Show like name the
iron dome is not a physical barrier it's
the name of Israel's mobile defense
system made up of about a dozen mobile
units that can fire missiles to
intercept rockets up to 45 miles away
it's been called a game-changer in fact
Israel says that the Iron Dome has
intercepted 90% of the targeted rockets
fired from Gaza since 2011 US taxpayers
have helped foot the bill by the end of
this year US contributions to the Iron
Dome program are set to reach 1 billion
dollars each interceptor missile costs
around $95,000 how does it work
basically Hamas launches a rocket radar
from the iron dome detects it a computer
determines where the rocket will land
and if the rocket is headed for a
populated area a commander has only 3 to
5 seconds to launch a missile to
intercept the rocket that's a quick
decision
[Music]